what if an app could tell you how long
before you die our phones have become
essential apps keep track of our
schedules our Fitness our love lives but
what if an app could tell you how long I
got 63 years 57 years before you died
would you want to know this it's fake
obviously my girlfriend said the same
thing I knew that app said she was gonna
die
whatever is happening to us I think it's
because of this CDs in your phone and
you following new number your service
[Music]
anything else I can help you with
No
[Music]
[Applause]
the countdown app it's really just a
random number with a clock it's not that
scary but it seems like it works on
YouTube clowns
this must be everyone that downloaded
the app she downloaded it all we need to
do is beat the clock by one second
have you ever done anything like this
before no but I've read about it a lot
this is a fate much worse than death
pursuing you come with me it won't
overwhelm you until you are utterly
destroyed
you're you calling my name
[Music]
you